[Music]
[Music]
Wow
hey whoa guys my name is the Cherno and
welcome back to another vlog today is
going to be a bit of a Q&A blog we'll be
answering some of the questions that you
guys sent in I'm all the way over here
in Germany so the view is pretty nice
should be pretty cool got some sweet
b-roll for you guys to enjoy and let's
take a look at what we've got here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and char
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
about a week ago I put up a post on
Instagram asking you guys to leave some
questions in the comments if you want to
be an answer from your questions for a
Q&A vlog this is it I'm just the Cherno
on Instagram so definitely follow me
there I am actually rather active there
I post quite a lot of photos and stuff
like that and occasionally you get cool
stuff like Q&A s so let me ask them some
questions from Instagram today you guys
sent in like a hundred questions so I'm
definitely not going to be able to get
through all of them I think I might
recycle some of them for future vlogs
and maybe answer them in the middle of
logs I'll just make another Q&A blog or
something like that but today we're just
going to go through a few of them which
I quite liked and I thought would be
helpful for people in general the first
of all so start off with an easy one
syllabic ATIS says where is Sparky mate
so fuzzy who don't know is Sparky is a
game engine that I started in probably
2015 so probably just over two years old
now I kind of stopped working on in a
year ago so to speak but I didn't really
start working on it that's the cool
that's a cool thing I stopped pushing to
github so it kind of seems like I've
been inactive but I have been kind of
working on it off the grid just offline
I haven't been pushing stuff because I
did kind of a large refactor and I
didn't want to break what was on github
and I don't know like I mean obviously I
could have made a branch or something
like that but I just I just didn't deal
with it and so at that point there were
so many changes that I didn't I didn't
want to push it really until it was done
and then I started adding features and
Sparky right now is actually a lot more
developed than it was I will eventually
probably push that out but if you guys
want to see more Sparky content or
anything like that you just leave a
comment below of people I can get to
maybe doing a few more development logs
or something in the future I don't think
I've spent that much time on it like
don't don't think that I'm working on
this thing everyday or anything but
there have been a lot of improvements
that have been made and I don't know if
you guys are just interested in Sparky
in general and kind of a 3d game engine
development stuff in general then yeah
leave a comment below lorenz earlier
asks optimization is something
potentially really long income
next how can you learn about it where
should you start have you some good
books or articles about that
optimization I will say this
optimization is something that comes
with experience you can learn to write
code relatively quickly and you can
learn to write pretty decent code
relatively quickly
however like in order for you to
actually start optimizing code without
you know spending massive amount of time
than having to having to research having
to research everything that you write
you just you're just going to have to
you're going to have to like gain that
experience and that takes time and
you'll just get that throughout the year
I know that a quote a lot of people
follow religiously is premature
optimization is the root of all evil I
don't really agree with that I think
that if you're a good enough programmer
you will be optimizing from the get-go
obviously not doubling the time it takes
you to do something because you've
decided to optimize from the beginning
but you should be aware optimization in
the beginning there's no reason to write
slow code if you know how to write fast
code from the beginning but I would say
that ultimately my tips for learning
optimization would be to first of all
understand the environment that you're
dealing with nor what you can do with
your current hardware or with your
current setup so whether whether that be
a my setup I mean even languages like
Java and C++ optimization what you can
do in terms of optimization between
those two languages it's actually going
to be rather different because this
office is going to allow you to do a lot
more kind of low level optimizations
with how you kind of access memory and
all that whereas with Java I mean you'll
still be probably optimizing memory
access however it might be like the way
that you'll do that is going to be at a
higher level which is almost easier in a
sense that it forces you to kind of
think about stuff more on a conceptual
point if that makes any sense
I think I'll definitely make some videos
about optimization in the future because
it's something that gets asked quite a
lot the C++ series that I'm doing as
well once we actually have finished
basics I'm actually going to try and
over these next few weeks I'm in Germany
I'm on kind of holidays I'm going to see
if I can knock out like a lot of videos
I want and just put them all up like
maybe even daily or something like that
for a week or so just to get past all
these basic topics
but once we do actually start getting
into writing code and writing data
structures and C++ there are going to be
a lot of videos about how to optimize
that so if you're interesting
optimization to craft that but anyway
data breach seven asks how many guitars
do you own what kinds are they how long
have you been playing for what's the
course liquor if you can play to chant
so I've been playing guitar for probably
11 years now I'm mostly I've kind of
gone between acoustic and electric how
many guitars do I own I want to say
about nine maybe ten um
three of them are electric if you can't
bass I don't know and a few counting
bass guitars but I think I've got three
electric guitars or the four I've got
four electric guitars three three like
steel string acoustic guitars and nylon
string acoustic and two bass guitars so
whatever that adds up to that to make it
out there I've also been playing piano
for what since I was four so was that
like seventeen I'm not I'm not 21
eighteen years but eighteen years of
piano eleven years of guitar what's a
cool lurker if I can play oh I don't
know i haven't played electric guitar
for a while so I kind of kind of end up
going between acoustic and electric a
lot currently I'm in a bit of an
acoustic train because I've been
listening to some ed Sheeran but I
definitely don't Ghent though I'm not
really into that kind of stuff I was in
a bit of amused cover band back in the
day so I can pretty much play anything
that music and play on guitar so yeah
all right we're gonna ask one more
question by Sam k95 how much can you
program without using the internet just
curious every time I try to use the
internet to help with my code I feel
guilty yeah programming offline is
something that I believe personally
every programmer should be able to do
not everyone can do that and that's like
okay if you're like the type of person
who can't program at all without the
internet but as soon as they have
internet access and things and can
Google things they're just amazing and
can get stuff done immediately then
obviously you're still a good programmer
because it takes more than just it takes
a good programmer to be able to write
code even if you do rely
the Internet me I kind of like to have
the ability to program without the
internet I remember when I was learning
programming I would pretty much write
the same code over and over again and
because of that like then I would come
home and I would write I would try and
make a game from scratch and at that
point I really only knew one kind of way
to do that so I would basically just
every night and I would never finish
these games obviously I mean One Nights
I'm not to make a game but I would um I
would kind of I would get home from
school and I would write basically the
same code over and over again to the
point where I could probably sit I could
definitely sit down and in fact I
remember I even printed that code and
put it into like a display folder and
took it with me to camp so I was on like
a mountain in my tent at night with a
flashlight
reading reading code on paper so yeah
that's pretty offline and so because I
was kind of getting home and writing a
code a lot I could probably sit down in
an exam room and on a piece of paper
write you a game from scratch and I'm
not even talking about like just a like
a Unity game script I'm talking about
like a software rasterizer in like Java
just on paper but like with the game and
it would probably probably compile I
mean I've never tried that I don't know
how far I'd get but I'm actually pretty
confident I could do something like that
that's how well I need to code so being
able to program offline is something
that isn't that necessary nowadays no
one's going to like I mean in a job
interview maybe people will ask you to
describe an algorithm and obviously you
can't just look it up on your phone or
something you'll have to actually
verbally take them through the code
basically that's in your mind and that
might be a bit difficult if you're used
to not doing anything like that ever was
even the question so yeah I mean I can
program without the internet pretty
comfortably it does help me a lot
especially if I'm dealing with
technology some of that that comfortable
with like if I was writing some kind of
true UI stuff in WPF which is
Microsoft's Windows presentation
foundation which is like a GUI library
things that Microsoft used for their
desktop application if I'm if I'm
writing code in WPF I would need the
internet because I'm not that
comfortable
and I can't just you know I can't just
bit out code like I need I need an API
reference whether that be on the
internet or even just having a book that
is just like an API reference like I
kind of need that you can get pretty far
by the way by just looking up like
header file if you're programming in C++
looking at the header file maybe they've
got comments there you can try that
right try and use an API you're not
comfortable with
hopefully they provide comments if not
maybe it's open source so you can look
at the source code and see what it
actually does a lot of people feel
intimidated by that but you don't really
a lot of the time source code is
actually a lot easier to read than you
think especially if it's just one
function at a time but if you want to
get better at programming offline you
need to start programming offline just
take your laptop out to a field
obviously you could just be disciplined
enough to not look at the internet and
be at home but I like the idea of taking
a laptop to a forest and just see what
you can do from scratch write a game and
in whatever tool you're using whether
that be unity or your own engine or
something like that try and do something
offline completely offline and see how
far you get if you don't get very far
and think about what you needed maybe
even make a list of the things where I
wish like Google did or I need it to
Google this and I couldn't make a list
of that stuff and maybe next time once
you look that up at home you can
remember it and next time you can give
it another shot but ultimately I mean
the way that you get better at it is you
just you just need to practice alright
thank you very much for those people who
did submit their questions if you guys
have any more questions for me you can
leave them in the comments below
I've still got a ton of questions to get
thrown into ramps expect some other
videos in the future but as always thank
you for watching and I will see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]